l'autre jour notre premier ministre jean
castex a prévenu désormais c'est fini
d'entrée sur le territoire français
comme dans un moulin
en premier lieu nous allons durcir
fortement les conditions d'entrée sur le
territoire national et renforcer les
contrôles le contrôle aux frontières des
mesures fermes donc on devrait enfin un
an après les premiers cas venus de chine
connaître des contrôles aux frontières
sauf qu'il y a un nez à compter de lundi
tous les voyageurs qui souhaitent venir
en france en provenance d'un pays
extérieurs à l'union européenne quels
qu'ils soient devront effectuer un test
avant de partir oui vous avez bien
entendu les tests pcr pour venir en
france ne seront donc obligatoire que si
vous venez d'un pays en dehors de
l'union européenne donc si vous venez
d'australie par exemple où il n'y a
quasiment plus de 4 vide
vous devrez présenter un test pcr
obligatoires au demeurant si vous venez
d'espagne comme c'est un pays de l'union
européenne vous ne subirez aucun
contrôle pourtant le pays connaît une
résurgence des cas allez comprendre
mais ce n'est pas tout de plus les
personnes concernées devront s'engager
sur l'honneur à s'isoler pendant sept
jours
une fois arrivés en france puis à
refaire un deuxième test pcr alice les
voyageurs hors zone union européenne
devront donc s'engager à respecter un
isolement sur l'honneur cette mesure
promet d'être efficace évidemment devant
cet arsenal de mesures hémiplégique
certains hommes politiques ont posé des
questions pourquoi ne pas simplement
tester pour commencer tous les voyageurs
union européenne comprise je pense que
c'est une décision collective que les
vingt-sept doivent prendre qu'elle
s'applique en france j'y suis favorable
ça peut aller jusqu'à la fermeture des
frontières entre notre pays et l'irlande
par exemple si on n'arrive pas en
irlande à à contenir cette pandémie et
cette nouvelle variété de virus une
mesure qui semble a priori logique mais
pour clément bonne secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères ce n'est qu'une
piste de réflexion
c'est une piste sur laquelle nous
travaillons qui fera l'objet de
discussions lors de la réunion de lundi
est peut-être lors du conseil européen
de jeudi l'allemagne et l'italie par
exemple l'appliquent déjà pour les
ressortissants français ou ceux des
autres états membres
et oui les allemands eux ne se sont pas
privés d'exiger ce test pour leurs
voisins français depuis le 14 janvier il
donc obligatoire de réaliser un test pcr
pour entrer sur le territoire allemand à
compter du 14 janvier 2021
outre l'obligation d'enregistrement il
est obligatoire de se soumettre à un
test de dépistage et de pouvoir en
apporter la preuve pour entrer sur le
territoire allemand depuis le 14 janvier
il est donc obligatoire de réaliser un
test pcr pour entrer sur le territoire
allemand
reste qu'en france un an après les
premiers cas on commence enfin à se
poser la question de faire de même
cependant si les difficultés n'avait été
que technique cela ferait bien longtemps
qu'elle aurait été surmontée le souci
est donc ailleurs
et c'est le jdd qui nous l'a révélé ce
week-end la vraie raison de cette
procrastination et idéologiques et
politiques
on refuse de jouer avec le symbole de la
frontière d'en faire une protection
illusoire qui donnerait l'impression que
le virus est ailleurs décrypte un
ministre pour le jdd pour un autre
responsable cette mesure est illusoire
dans un espace européen où les limites
entre états se franchissent à vélo ça
peut rassurer la population car les gens
ont l'impression qu'on fait les choses
bien mais ça ne marche pas et voilà on
en revient au fameux virus qui n'a pas
de passeport comme l'affirmé l'année
dernière emmanuel macron sauf que 6
décembre nous a appris quelque chose
c'est bien que le virus a un passeport
dans ses formes mutantes
il est désormais anglais sud africains
brésiliens et les voyageurs portant des
variants présente un risque de relancer
l'épidémie en australie par exemple on a
compris la situation cinq sur cinq est
depuis longtemps depuis le 20 mars 2020
les frontières sont fermées à toute
personne non résidentes sauf
autorisation spéciale
et même si vous êtes citoyen australien
testou pas test on vous met carrément en
quarantaine pendant deux semaines toutes
les personnes arrivant sur le territoire
par voie aérienne ou maritime y compris
les citoyens et résidents australiens
seront obligatoirement placés en
quarantaine pendant 14 jours dans une
installation désigné dans la ville
d'arrivée comme par hasard
l'australie caracole actuellement au top
du classement des pays qui gère le mieux
l'épidémie assises n'est actuellement
pas de confinement le masque n'est pas
obligatoire dans la rue et il n'ya
presque plus de cas mais ça n'a bien sûr
aucun rapport avec la politique menée